what I did hopefully after you guys kind
of hear my reasoning you guys can kind
of understand my side a little bit
Isaac Presley is speaking out about his
breakup with Kensi Ziegler I'm sure you
can tell by the title of this video I'm
gonna be talking about Ken's and i's
breakup I have nothing but love for
Ken's and everything she's done like
Kenzie's literally I have not one
negative thing to say in a video posted
on Sunday the 17 year old actor shared
his side of the story following their
split sometimes when people break up it
doesn't really have to do with like they
had bad blood it's just sometimes timing
doesn't work out where you know it's
just something that's not really in the
control of both sides the fuller house
actor also responded to allegations he
cheated on the 15 year old singer
despite allegations I did not cheat on
Ken's you guys literally if she you guys
aren't in our personal lives so what you
guys see is only a certain layer of
reality it's just like something you're
seeing but you don't know the full story
behind it I haven't ever addressed the
situation because it's beneath me and
the only people that matter to know like
the truth was Kenda it's our
relationship meanwhile Kensi made her
own comments in a Q&A posted on her
channel on Sunday what I want to do
right now is just chill be single not
worry about boys because literally you
guys know me I love boys but like
seriously like I rush into things super
super fast and then I regret it so right
now I'm living my life I need to just be
single and live my life because it's I'm
having a great time the breathe singer
also seemingly referenced those cheating
allegations and said she might not be so
public with her future relationships
thoughts on public relationships my past
relationships I wish I didn't put them
on social media the pair first seemed a
couple up last summer with these PDA
filled post on Instagram by October the
relationship was on full display hey
guys
you are doing the girlfriend says yeah
and in December
Kenzie gusts all about Isaac to ET we
melt a little bit every time you guys
post something adorable and couples
Goldsworthy on your Instagram what is it
about that guy that just kind of like
makes your heart flutter he's literally
the sweetest person he's so supportive
with everything he's coming here and
supporting and he like I told it was
like you do not need to come and he's
like no I'm gonna be there for like five
hours like I would never do that I'm
sorry but no he's literally one of my
favorite people he's always there for me
and like he just loves everything that I
do he doesn't listen to a lot of like
this style of music but like he just
loves everything that I do so he's
really awesome
are we exchanging the l-word your your
life is so crazy how does it feel to
have like a constant like that kind of
like dis Heaton do you guys go off of
each other and give each other advice
cuz he's in the industry you're in the
industry yeah for sure we kind of just
like do it together and like you know
grow together we don't really like
talked about social media because we're
not really like social media influencers
I would say yeah but he always gives me
just like life advice he's really good
at that
[Music]